if you were on a debate stage with
Rhonda Santos what would you say to him
what would be your interactions with him
when they say he's not a very good
debater but maybe he is I don't know
we'll find out maybe we'll find out
Because unless he gets close why would
anybody debate all right so Trump there
suggesting he might not even debate
DeSantis unless DeSantis gets close in
polling yeah I mean listen Trump doesn't
look good I think what's going on here
and I'm not trying to be funny or
disrespectful or anything is when Trump
doesn't have
the you know the the dyed hair perfectly
quaffed and perfectly for Trump is an
open to interpretation the spray tan the
suit the entire thing
Trump's an obese older guy and so this
is just what he looks like I think I
think it's that simple I don't know that
Trump is sick necessarily